[Music]
in healthwatch there may be something
lurking in your sunscreen you
didn't know about a chemical linked to
cancer denise valdez joins us live in
studio with the warning denise
so christian imagine you're putting the
sunscreen on to avoid cancer and there's
a cancer threat in the actual
product some of it linked to even
leukemia so online pharmacy and lab is
asking the fda to recall some popular
sunscreen products
after they ran independent tests with
summer almost here
people are spending more time in the sun
but tests by valley shure an online
pharmacy and lab
show dozens of popular sunscreens and
after sun products
contain a chemical tied to blood cancers
benzene
a known carcinogen was found in 27
percent of the sprays and lotions tested
that includes products sold by
neutrogena banana boat
and cbs the problem with benzene is it
can cause leukemia anemia things like
this
cbs chief medical correspondent dr john
lapook says one of the things the fda
will look into
is how the chemical is getting into the
products there's no manufacturer
that's intentionally adding it to the
sunscreen product
somehow it's in there as a contaminant
it's not clear how it gets in there
is it one of the ingredients that got
contaminated is it the process of making
the lotion or the after sun product that
somehow creates it we're not sure
johnson and johnson maker of neutrogena
products told cbs news
benzene is not an ingredient in any of
our personal care products
cbs said the products it sells are safe
and quote we're in the process of
reviewing and evaluating information
related to value sure's petition and
will respond accordingly
and the maker banana boat said quote our
sun care products undergo
rigorous testing to ensure safety and
quality
meet all fda regulations not all the
products from those brands were found to
contain benzene
health experts emphasize the vast
majority of sunscreens
do not contain the chemical and people
still need to protect themselves from
the sun
you might feel more comfortable using an
organic product for now
experts who conducted the study believe
the issue is manufacturing
it's a contamination that might happen
when those chemicals interact
and it may only affect specific batches
but there are 78 sunscreens on that list
so you can check that list you can see
if your sunscreen might have benzene in
it
a link is available at valley shore
that's v-a-l-i-sure.com